[Musique]
un mystère qui durait depuis plus de
3200 ans devient la plus grande
découverte archéologique du ciel grâce
au courage et à l'intuition d'un homme
un pharaon oublié reprend sa place dans
l'histoire l'enfant roi tout en Camon
la découverte de la tombe de
Toutankhamon est la plus grande
découverte archéologique
cette découverte lieu le 4 novembre 1922
avoir de Carter faisait des fouilles
dans la Vallée des Rois et le porteur
d'eau trouve à l'entrée
avoir Carter arriva à l'entrée et trouve
à la tombe qu'il cherchait depuis 5 ans
[Musique]
le 4 novembre 1922 l'archéologue anglais
Howard Carter découvre 16 marches d'un
escalier qui mène à la tombe de
Toutankhamon
la tombe est intacte personne n'y avait
pénétré auparavant mais ce n'est que 22
jours plus tard que Carter se rend
compte de l'importance de sa découverte
Howard Carter disait
le 26 novembre fut un jour clé le plus
beau jour de ma vie comme on peut
espérer qu'il y en ait un autre à la
moitié de l'après-midi près de 10 mètres
après cette porte on en trouvera une
deuxième
les sauts étaient encore plus difficiles
à déchiffrer mais le saut de
Toutankhamon et celui de l'un nécropole
royale était encore lisible
rapidement tout s'éclaircissait il
suffisait de casser la porte murée pour
trouver les réponses à nos questions
peu à peu et d'une manière qui nous
semblait désespérément lente tous les
gravats qui recouvraient la partie
inférieure de la porte furent enlevées
et enfin le mur d'obturation devint
entièrement visible ce fut le moment
décisif
[Musique]
face à ce mur Howard Carter a-t-il pensé
se trouver à un pas de la découverte
archéologique du 20e siècle un événement
qui rendrait son nom immortel ainsi que
celui du pharaon qu'il Monette à la
lumière tout en Camon
jusqu'à ce jour Toutankhamon était qu'un
nom oublié des siècles durant un pharaon
qui ne vécut pas suffisamment longtemps
pour laisser un signe tangible de son
passage sur terre
un pharaon dont le nom n'apparaissait
même pas sur les listes royales des
dynasties de l'Égypte ancienne
[Musique]
ces listes furent en fait interrompues
entre aménotep 3 et Or en
omettant les noms de 4 souverains les
Pharaons surnommés hérétiques
Akhenaton semaine Cara
et bien sûr Toutankhamon
Toutankhamon était un des rois de la 18e
dynastie
c'était un jeune roi qui mourut à l'âge
de 18 ou 19 ans
[Musique]
il y a une sorte de secret ou de mystère
sur la manière dont il est mort
l'enfant pharaon vécu et régna pendant
une des périodes les plus troubles de
l'histoire de l'Égypte
il devint roi peu après la mort
d'Akhenaton le souverain qui mena a bien
une révolution sociale politique et
religieuse sans précédent
[Musique]
le panthéon égyptien fut remplacé par un
Dieu unique à ton le soleil pour lequel
Akhenaton construisit une ville entière
telle elle Amarna et ferme à tous les
temples dédiés aux autres dieux
à la mort du pharaon une période trouble
s'ensuit pendant laquelle les prêtres
d'amont le Dieu tout-puissant par 20 à
rétablir la situation antérieure
toutank amour ramena de nouveau le
centre religieux du pays à Carnac
et de nombreux éléments Akhenaton avait
fait pour changer le culte d'attent et
pour faire disparaître le culte
d'amonere furent détruit
le centre religieux revint à Carnac et à
mondray de 20 à nouveau le dieu le plus
important
les temples d'Akhenaton furent démontés
et les pierres réutilisées dans d'autres
monuments
ce qui est pratique car certains temples
ont été préservés malheureusement de
manière fragmentée
entre 139 avant Jésus-Christ avec le
soutien des mêmes prêtres tout en Camon
de vin pharaons à l'âge de 9 ans
avant la découverte de sa tombe codifiée
sous le numéro kV 62 on savait peu de
choses sur ce jeune roi
mais aujourd'hui il est bien plus connu
que n'importe quel autre pharaon
d'Égypte ancienne
[Musique]
toutefois certains aspects de sa vie
restant de mystères
comme par exemple l'identité de ses
parents
si on regarde la famille de Toutankamon
comme je l'ai dit précédemment certains
spécialistes pensent que son père était
amène au top 3 je pense que son père
était Akhenaton sa mère pour moi était
la reine qui a mais certaines pensent
qu'il s'agit de Néfertiti
nous ne savons pas vraiment
même sans l'existence de preuves
archéologiques qui nous fournissent une
réponse certaine sur les parents de
Toutankhamon il semble certain qu'il est
né et qu'il a vécu son enfance à tel
Amarna
cette hypothèse nous est suggérée par
plusieurs facteurs tout d'abord son nom
Toutankhamon pendant les premières
années de sa vie signifie l'image
vivante daton la tombe royale à marna
comporte également un mur avec la
représentation des funérailles de
mekhetathon une des filles d'Akhenaton
et donnée fertiti
selon une théorie mais qui est à ton
mourut en couche en donnant naissance en
fait à Toutankhamon que l'on représente
sous la forme d'un bébé dans les bras
d'une mère nourricière
selon certains experts cependant
l'enfant pharaon était le beau-fils
d'Akhenaton car il avait épousé une des
filles du pharaon hérétique et de
Néfertiti mais il existe encore une
autre théorie qui semble plus probable
nous pensons qu'il était le fils
d'Akhenaton à 90%
toutes les preuves que nous avons nous
disent qu'il était un des enfants
d'Akhenaton
n'avait que des filles de la très
célèbre reine Néfertiti 6 filles il
n'avait pas de fils de Néfertiti c'est
pour cela qu'il avait une deuxième femme
dont le nom est Kia
et c'est qu'il y a qui a porté le fils
d'Akhenaton
il semblerait que le jeune toutankhamon
est épousé sa demi-sœur
la seule certitude que nous ayons et que
le garçon fut couronné a-t-elle elle à
Marnaz mais qui abandonna rapidement
cette ville pour revenir à Thèbes où il
changea son nom pour celui de
Toutankhamon l'image vivante d'Amont
[Musique]
on ne trouve pas de changement des noms
des temples pour attester de sa présence
sur tout type de document confondus ici
essentiellement
qui se trouve à même fils oui
temple
on sait que l'époque des Ammann est
terminée
et peu d'année se sont écoulés entre la
mode de Akhenaton
de la période en manque peut être pas
plus de 3 à 4 roues
[Musique]
la première tâche qui incombe au très
jeune pharaon et de réintroduire le
culte d'Amont
le pays était accablé les sanctuaires
des dieux tombés en ruine
j'ai prié les dieux et les déesses afin
qu'ils m'aident mais ils ne m'ont pas
écouté
j'ai œuvré constamment afin de regagner
leur faveur
quand je suis arrivé j'ai trouvé leur
temple détruit les lieux sacrés profanés
et les cours recouvertes d'herbes folles
j'ai reconstruit leur sanctuaire j'ai
rénové les temples et je leur ai offert
de nombreuses offrandes précieuses
j'ai fait faire les statuts des dieux en
or
t'incruster de la pile azulie et
d'autres pierres précieuses
[Musique]
la réintroduction du culte d'amont était
une décision très importante que
Toutankhamon ne pouvait prendre à lui
seul
après la mort d'Akhenaton et le retour
de la cour à Thèbes le culte d'amanderey
redevint extrêmement puissant
le très jeune âge de Toutankhamon
permettait au prêtre d'exercer une
influence sur lui et de se réapproprier
le pouvoir caténaton leur avaient enlevé
ce rétablissement fut suivi d'un retour
à Thèbes en tant que capitale du royaume
[Musique]
dans le grand complexe des temples
d'amour à Carnac il fut construire une
grande avenue bordée de sphinx sa tête
de bélier ce qui reliait le temple
d'amont à celui de Moute sa femme divine
de plus il réintroduisit la fait
ancienne dopée qui était la fête de
dévotion la plus solennelle à la
triadeben formée par Hamon mouth et
conso
[Musique]
un Louxor il fait ériger une statue de
lui-même et de sa femme que l'on
attribue à plus tard à Ramsès II
toutefois ses proches de cette statue
que l'activité de Toutankhamon en
matière de travaux publics athénie son
paroxysme
[Musique]
nous nous trouvons dans la procession de
colonne du temple de Louxor qui fut
commencé sous amenotep 3 et abandonné
sous Akhenaton
ses colonnes sont un témoignage de la
dévotion de Toutankhamon à amonneray car
il acheva une grande partie de ses
merveilleux décors
[Musique]
malgré sa célébrité tout en Camon créa
peu de choses
son règne ne dira que 10 ans
il mourut avant même d'avoir 20 ans
ce fut une mort soudaine qui surprit
tout le monde y compris ceux qui
travaillaient à la construction de son
tombeau
quand l'enfant roi mourut le lieu pour
son repos éternel en fait n'était pas
encore prêt et son corps embaumé fut
placé dans un autre lieu de repos
indigne d'accueillir un roi
il s'agit en fait d'une chambre
funéraire de petite taille composée d'un
couloir court qui mène dans une
antichambre devant une zone réduite
dénommée annexe dans laquelle on
conservait les objets et la nourriture
dont le pharaon aurait besoin dans l'eau
de la
à partir de l'antichambre on peut
atteindre la chambre funéraire et le
petit trésor
[Musique]
dans l'ensemble la tombe est de
dimensions modeste pas plus de 100
mètres carrés mais elle est dans des
lieux les plus fascinants et les plus
importants associés à l'histoire de
l'Égypte
[Musique]
la célébrité de Toutankhamon est due à
la découverte de sa tombe la seule
trouvait intacte dans la Vallée des Rois
grâce à la ténacité et à l'intuition de
Ward Carter
[Musique]
Carter commença les fouilles dans la
Vallée des Rois en 1907
il était financé par George Edouard
Herbert Earl de carnaval
mais pendant de nombreuses années les
fous ils ne donnèrent pas le résultat
escompté
ce n'est qu'après des années de
recherche que finalement le 4 novembre
1922 l'archéologue anglais trouva ce
qu'il cherchait
[Musique]
et trouve les ouvriers silencieux
et le contremaître vient vers lui et lui
dit
nous avons trouvé quelque chose que vous
devriez voir
et il emmène sur le site à un endroit
précis et lui montre la première marge
de la tombe
à ce moment Carter ne sait pas qu'il va
trouver la tombe de Toutankhamon mais il
est certain d'avoir enfin trouvé quelque
chose d'important dans la Vallée des
Rois donc il descend les marches vers la
tombe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après avoir fini de nettoyer l'escalier
il parvient à une entrée qu'il trouve
bouchée avec les sauts de la nécropole
de la Vallée des Rois
il appelle James afin de lire ensemble
le nom inscrit sur ses sceaux et il voit
qu'il s'agit des sauts avec les
cartouches de Toutankhamon
il commence à comprendre qu'il s'agit de
la tombe de Toutankhamon
mais il trouve également deux sauts qui
indiquent que la tombe a été ouverte
après les funérailles de Toutankhamon
il a donc quelques soupçons que la tombe
ait pu être cambriolée dans l'Antiquité
vous imaginez ces deux sauts qui cellent
cette porte lui donnent des doutes quant
à la tombe est-elle intacte ou pas
mais il poursuit les fouilles et il
envoie un message à Lord Carnavon afin
qu'ils viennent le rejoindre pour cette
découverte
[Musique]
lorsqu’un le rejoint alors qu'il finit
ce couloir et ils atteignent la tombe à
l'autre entrée
[Musique]
jusqu'à son arrivée toutes les entrées
étaient fermées et scellées avec les
noms de Toutankhamon
et là à cet endroit lorsqu'un avion le
rejoint et il se met à briser les sceaux
ou cette porte afin de voir ce qui se
trouve à l'intérieur
Carter allume une bougie pour voir ce
qui se trouve à l'intérieur et lorsqu’un
avant lui demande que voyez-vous que
voyez-vous
et il répond je vois une lueur d'or à
l'intérieur
ce qui signifie que la tombe était
intacte quand il la voit pour la
première fois
il voit également avec lorsqu'un avent
pour la première fois que la tombe est
remplie d'objets des milliers et des
milliers d'objets la tombe déborde
d'objets c'est un grand moment pour eux
vous savez ce qu'ils ont trouvé se
trouve dans tous les livres
d'égyptologie car ce fut un grand moment
pour l'histoire de l'égyptologie et
aussi car pour la première fois on
trouvait une tombe intacte dans la
Vallée des Rois
fini d'ouvrir le passage dans cette
pièce ou en tichambre il trouve une
pièce remplie de milliers et de milliers
d'objets la plupart d'entre eux en or et
en pierre précieuse ou semi-précieuse
tout était disposé et enveloppé très
soigneusement prêt à tenir compagnie au
roi dans son voyage dans l'au-delà
en 1927 il commence à travailler vers
l'ouest jusqu'à atteindre un grand mur
et là il y a une entrée scellée avec des
cartouches de Toutankhamon
à un moment clé l'antichambre était
presque dégagé et il allait casser le
mur qui le séparait de la chambre
funéraire où il espérait trouver la
momie de Pharaon encore intact
[Musique]
Howard Carter disait avec un soin
extrême je cassais le plâtre et
commencer à retirer les petites pierres
qui formaient le haut de la partie
supérieure du mur
le désir de tout arrêter pour regarder
l'intérieur était irrésistible et quant
au bout de 10 minutes le trou était
suffisamment grand pour regarder à
l'intérieur j'insérais une lampe torche
la lumière me révéla un spectacle
ahurissant
la vingtaine de personnes qui se
trouvaient dans le tombeau à côté de
Carter lui demandèrent s'il voyait
quelque chose
ce à quoi l'archéologue répondit oui des
merveilles encore la voix de warcarter
environ un mètre de la porte en quelques
directions que ce soit une quantité
importante de matériaux bloque l'accès à
la chambre ce n'était rien d'autre qu'un
mur en or massif
[Musique]
car les tombeaux les tombeaux en bois
dorés qui recouvraient les sarcophages
du roi se trouvaient juste derrière ce
mur
et il se mirent à soulever les tombeaux
si tombeaux systématiquement l'un après
l'autre jusqu'à atteindre ce merveilleux
sarcophage en quartzite
puis il soulevèrent le haut du
sarcophage
une fois la partie supérieure du
sarcophage enlevé Carter trouva le
sarcophage extérieur fait en or massif
puis il l'ouvrir et trouvèrent un autre
sarcophage fait en bois doré et quand il
le soulevèrent il se retrouvèrent face à
la momie
malgré la taille réduite la tombe est
recouverte représentation qui ont toutes
beaucoup à nous raconter
regardez au début on peut voir les
funérailles
on amène la momie de tout un Cameron
dans un tombeau et on a même la momie au
tombeau
puis après cela nous avons aïe le grand
prêtre qui devint roi d'Egypte qui ouvre
la bouche de toutankhamones
et lui dit
[Musique]
je t'ouvre la bouche afin que tu puisses
manger
je t'ouvre les yeux afin que tu puisses
voir
je t'ouvre le nez afin que tu puisses
respirer dans l'au-delà et tu deviendras
roi
puis vous avez des scènes de
Toutankhamon en compagnie de Dieu en
particulier à tort
la déesse de la beauté de l'amour
et Osiris
regardez ils tiennent avec amour et
affection
Osiris lui dit
viens dans mon royaume tu deviendras
l'un d'entre nous tu deviendras Dieu
et à tort tout comme Isis sa mère le
tien avec amour
[Musique]
et un extrait du livre dame du Havre ce
que l'on trouve dans l'eau de la
et puis nous voyons Anubis qui bénit
également tout un canal
[Musique]
peu de scène mais toute très importante
qui nous montre qu'aux iris acceptait le
roi toute qui reposait sous des
cercueils au nord
pour vivre pour l'éternité
la nouvelle de la découverte se répand
rapidement dans le monde entier et elle
devient encore plus sensationnel de par
une supposée malédiction qui semble
frapper ceux qui ont pris part à la
découverte
on dit en fait qu'à l'intérieur de la
chambre funéraire on trouva une tablette
en terre cuite qui disparue par la suite
avec une inscription explicite
les ailes de la mort frapperon quiconque
osera déranger le repos du pharaon
à l'époque on apporte à différentes
versions de la malédiction mais toutes
s'accordait à rendre responsable pour
tout événement malheureux la colère du
pharaon dont le repos éternel avait été
dérangé après près de 33 siècles
ce qui donna naissance à cette légende
fut la mort soudaine de Lord carnaval
quelques mois après la découverte
dans les années qui suivirent plusieurs
personnes associées même indirectement à
la découverte de la tombe eurent
différents accidents
pour cette raison de nombreux journaux
se rendirent compte que la malédiction
était une information plus fascinante
que la découverte en elle-même est
contribuèrent à l'entretenir en
rapportant la moindre rumeur
et encore de nos jours la malédiction
continue de faire la une
j'ai pris la momie et je l'ai introduite
dans l'appareil à tomographie et ce qui
est surprenant c'est qu'après avoir mis
le corps du roi tout à l'intérieur de
l'appareil à tomographie l'appareil
s'est arrêté je me suis mise à penser
qu'il y a peut-être quelque chose que
l'on pourrait appeler la malédiction des
pharaons ou la malédiction de
Toutankhamon pourquoi l'appareil
s'était-il arrêté même si la tombe était
de taille limitée on y trouvait 5398
objets en or et en argent le plus grand
trésor jamais découvert
[Musique]
on séduit le cœur de tout le monde
chaque objet nous raconte une histoire
anajim alimentaire par exemple
il aimait la bière nous avons un grand
nombre de cruches à bière
nous nous intéressons à la nourriture
nous avons de nombreuses informations
sur la nourriture et l'alimentation du
roi la tombe peut nous raconter des
choses sur ce jeune homme qui a régnait
pour une si courte période mais c'était
un âge d'or
on a retrouvé des dizaines de vases et
d'animaux en albâtre le trésor dans sa
grande partie était composé d'un
reliquaire en or qui protégeait 4 vases
canope en albâtre ces derniers
contenaient les organes internes du
jeune pharaon
trois magnifiques têtes de lit en bois
dorée
occupaient tout le mur de l'antichambre
où se trouvait également 700 objets
parmi ceux-ci un splendide trône doré
avec une des plus rares représentation
de Toutankhamon avec sa femme principale
encaissée d'un monde
le couple royal est représenté dans un
moment de grande intimité car la femme
implique un Angus parfumé sur le corps
du souverain
les deux jeunes gens sont représentés
avec une seule sandale aux pieds un
signe de l'amour éternel qu'il s'était
mutuellement juré tant dans les temps
meilleurs symbolisés par le pied chaussé
de la sandale que dans les temps
difficiles le pied nu
nous avons un très petit tombeau doré
ce tombeau est recouvert de scènes
merveilleusement belle
entre Toutankhamon et sa jeune femme
dans des pauses très différentes
les objets que nous avons ici
nous montre qu'ils étaient très amoureux
l'un de l'autre
même s'ils étaient très jeunes quand ils
se sont mariés
Toutankhamon a épousé encaissé namont
peu avant d'être couronné c'est à dire à
l'âge de 9 ans et au fil des ans leur
amour est devenu plus profond
ils étaient amoureux tout dans cette
tombe nous le montre on le voit sur les
objets comme citron qui se trouve au
musée égyptien du Caire
regardez la reine elle se penche vers
lui elle touche quand il meurt elle met
cette fleur
et nous savons qu'il n'avait pas
d'enfants
les seules preuves que nous ayons sur le
fœtus qui montre qu'ils ont eu deux
enfants Mornay
[Musique]
nous espérons pouvoir faire des
prélèvements pour étudier la DN pour
trouver la relation entre ces fœtus et
le roi toutes
de tous ces objets retrouvés dans la
tombe les plus précieux sont ceux qui se
trouvaient dans la chambre funéraire
le corps du pharaon était protégé par
quatre tombeaux en bois doré les uns à
l'intérieur des autres
à l'intérieur se trouvait un grand
sarcophage en quartzite qui contenait
encore trois autres sarcophages les deux
premiers également en bois doré et le
troisième en or massif
Howard Carter disait en soulevant le
couvercle en utilisant les poignées
dorés et la momie du pharaon apparu
plus de 3000 ans s’étaient écoulées
depuis que des yeux humains avaient
contemplé ce qui se trouvait à
l'intérieur de ce cercueil en or massif
et en comparaison avec la brièveté de
l'existence humaine toute perspective
commune semblait disparaître devant nous
se trouvait allongé tout ce qui restait
du jeune pharaon qui jusqu'à ce jour
n'avait été que l'ombre d'un nom
[Musique]
le visage de la momie était protégé par
un merveilleux masque en or qui nous
indiquait la physionomie du pharaon
le plus bel objet sur terre le masque
j'ai l'impression qu'il parle
quand je le regarde
ce visage
ses yeux
il est vivant
à l'intérieur du masque se trouvait
graver un verre du texte du sarcophage
qui accompagnait le pharaon dans
l'au-delà
je te salue toi au doux visage
[Musique]
donna à Osiris pour la chose secrète qui
lui fut faite afin d'en finir avec le
tort que 7 lui fit puis tu le rendrait
sprit puisse tu soumettre ses ennemis
puisses-tu le guider vers les lieux
paisibles de royaume des morts
puisse-tu briser la conspiration de
cette
que je sois celui qui endure
endurer et ce qui a été ordonné enduré
comme ré pour toujours
enlevez le masque du visage du pharaon
n'était pas chaude et Carter sans
rendez-vous
il essaie de retirer le masque ce qui ne
parvient pas à faire car le masque était
complètement attaché au corps de la
momie
[Musique]
tire la momie de la tombe et la placer
sous le soleil
il ne parvint pas toujours pas à retirer
le masque
alors il amena la momie à l'intérieur de
la tombe de SETI 2 puis avec d'autres il
prirent différents outils et enlevèrent
le masque
et c'est de cette façon que Howard
Carter a complètement endommagé la momie
et la brisait en 18 morceaux
[Musique]
la manière de procéder de Carter et les
recherches sur la momie qui suivirent
ont laissé la momie dans un état très
détérioré ces dernières années de
nombreuses dispositions ont été prises
afin de préserver l'état de conservation
j'ai regardé le corps et je me suis dit
[Musique]
je dois sauver ces rois je dois sauver
cet enfant
à cause car la respiration des gens qui
ont entre à l'intérieur ou la poussière
peuvent détruire encore davantage la
momie
c'est pour cela que je suis venu le 4
novembre 2007 le jour anniversaire de la
découverte de la tombe
vous n'imaginez pas
la vallée était pleine de centaines de
journalistes du monde entier
l'enfant roi a tirait tout le monde
c'est pour cela que l'on a conçu cette
sorte de présentoir en Allemagne
j'ai enlevé la momie de son sarcophage
et je l'ai placé ici le seul parti que
l'on peut voir sur le visage et les
pieds étant dessous on peut voir le
contrôle du taux d'humidité et ainsi on
peut préserver la momie pendant un corps
de nombreuses années
[Musique]
les analyses ont donné des résultats
surprenants en particulier en ce qui
concerne un des mystères les plus
obscurs se rapportant à Toutankhamon la
véritable cause de sa mort soudaine
pendant des décennies la théorie la plus
acceptée était celle de l'homicide mais
aujourd'hui les analyses pratiquées par
le Conseil suprême des antiquités avec
les moyens technologiques les plus
avancés ont montré qu'il est mort d'un
simple accident
nous avons découvert qu'il n'avait pas
été tués comme on le pensait au siècle
dernier
[Musique]
les gens pensaient qu'il avait été tués
parce qu'après des analyses
on a trouvé une sorte de trou dans son
cerveau
mais ce n'est pas ça qui avait causé la
mort
qui n'a pas été assassiné
se trou à l'arrière de la tête
l'appareil à tomographique nous a montré
qu'il fut pratiqué à la 18e dynastie
afin de permettre la momification afin
de verser le liquide à l'intérieur du
corps
et j'ai ramené la momie et annoncé que
le roi toute
était mort dans un accident
car nous avons trouvé une fracture à la
jambe droite et cette fracture s'est
produite une journée avant sa mort
[Musique]
nous ne savons rien
et cependant jusqu'à ce moment-là on
pensait que les circonstances du décès
étaient différentes
1968 on a analysé la momie au rayon X
les résultats ont montré des tâches
suspectes au sommet du crâne
c'est à partir de cela que les théories
d'un complot et d'un homicide se sont
répandus
[Musique]
il y a eu un certain nombre de théories
quant à la manière dont toutankhamon est
mort une des plus répandues était qu'il
avait été tuée d'un coup derrière la
tête sa théorie reposait sur un examen
au rayon X que l'on avait pratiqué il y
a un certain temps et à partir de cette
image brouillée flou on a bâti une
théorie sur la manière dont il est mort
peut-être par un de ses conseillers aïe
ou un autre conseiller au remède
pourquoi aïe et aurait même en tant que
principaux suspects du crime qui était
ses hommes
qui selon certaines théories était le
père de Néfertiti avait des
responsabilités importantes sous le
règne d'Akhenaton
il était membre du conseil de régence
qui gouvernait l'Egypte avant que
Toutankhamon ne devienne Pharaon
les travaux de construction de son
tombeau furent commencé à tel el Amarna
mais ne furent jamais achevée car la
mort du jeune roi change à la situation
encaissez namont ne souhaitez pas
épouser un des prétendants au trône elle
écrivit au roi des hits
mon mari est mort et on m'a dit que vous
avez des fils adultes
envoyez-moi un et j'en ferai un prince
consort qui régnera sur l'Égypte
[Musique]
le souverain itite accepta la
proposition et envoyé un de ses fils à
la reine le prince cependant ne parvint
jamais à la cour de teb il fut tué
pendant son voyage vers l’égypte par des
assassins envoyés peut-être par ail
selon certaines théories encaisser d'un
monde épousa le vieux prétendant selon
d'autres elle ne l'épousa pas et on ne
sait rien d'autre d'elle
la seule certitude et que aille même
s'il n'était pas de son royal devant le
11e pharaon de la 18e dynastie
à 17 ans il parvient à satisfaire sa
plus grande ambition
[Musique]
aïe ce fut construit un magnifique
tombeau dans la Vallée des Rois le Cavé
23 où on l'enterrera sa mort juste
quatre ans après son accession au trône
aurait
il devint pharaon sans être de son royal
il était général un des hommes les plus
importants à l'époque vers la fin de la
18e dynastie
il prépare au Conseil de Régence qui
choisit Toutankhamon pour devenir
Pharaon et fut un de ceux qui lutta pour
le pouvoir à la mort de Toutankhamon
deux tombeaux sont conservés pour
oranais
avant de devenir roi il avait commencé
la construction d'une magnifique tombe
dans l'ancienne nécropole de Saqqara
[Musique]
dans la nécropole de Memphis un tombeau
qui devient de plus en plus grand avait
des cours de nouvelles colonnes
quand il devient roi il doit faire un
choix
ce tombeau ne convenait pas pour le
nouveau roi car les rois sont enterrés
dans la Vallée des Rois à Thèbes et à
Louxor
[Musique]
se prépare ton beau à Thèbes entre
parenthèses ailes avec peut-être un
tombeau à Sarah qui reste à découvrir
et pour neb c'est la même chose il se
fait construire une splendide tombe pour
lui dans la Vallée des Rois
la tombe dans un EB dans la Vallée des
Rois dénommé
kv57 semble inachevée
les murs de la chambre funéraires sont
décorés de scène en relief à différentes
étapes d'achèvement
mais elles sont très utiles pour
comprendre le processus que les artistes
suivaient pour obtenir ce type de
décoration
[Musique]
dans l'ensemble la tombe dorem heb est
une des plus grandes de la Vallée des
Rois et elle fait véritablement deux
fois la taille de celle de son
prédécesseur aïe le courtisan
manipulateur qui devint pharaon à la
mort de Toutankhamon
mais la tombe de ail retient un autre
mystère
en fait il semblerait qu'elle fut
construite au départ pour Toutankhamon
mais à la mort soudaine du jeune pharaon
l'ancien vizir l'aurait enterré dans la
tombe qui lui était destinée et qui à ce
moment-là était achevé
[Musique]
par chance c'est cette tombe la café 62
qui est resté intacte pendant plus de
3200 ans
s'il n'y avait pas eu ce concours de
circonstances peut-être qu'aujourd'hui
Toutankhamon ne serait pas le pharaon le
plus célèbre de l'histoire
[Musique]
et on n'aurait pas sa momie exposé dans
une vitrine dans la tombe la plus
célèbre au monde
[Applaudissements]
on peut aujourd'hui admirer le visage
d'un jeune pharaon un visage qui malgré
tout cache encore bien des secrets
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous allons bientôt comparer le ADN de
l'enfant roi avec le squelette
d'Akhenaton et nous pourrons découvrir
l'autre famille de Toutankhamon
roi
conservera toujours son mystère
le mystère et la magie de Toutankhamon
ne sont pas prêts de s'arrêter
tout continuera
Carter disait le mystère de la vie de
Toutankhamon continue de nos échapper
les
ombres se meurent mais l'obscurité ne se
dissipe jamais complètement
en général je découvre de nouvelles
tombes de nouvelles statues sous le
sable sur des sites mais cette fois-ci
je vous amène dans un lieu unique les
sous-sols du musée égyptien du Caire
nous allons y mener des fouilles nous
allons vous montrer des découvertes que
le grand public n'a jamais pu voir je
vais vous montrer la toute première
statue qui m'a donné cette passion cet
amour pour l'archéologie
inondé chaque année au beau milieu de
l'été par l'eau qui nourrit la terre
embrassé chaque jour par les rayons de
soleil
la vallée du Nil est devenue le berceau
d'une civilisation mythique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
plus d'un siècle s'est écoulé depuis que
c'était les gambattement néoclassique
dans le centre du Caire concentre plus
de 3000 ans d'histoire de l'ancienne
Égypte
le musée détient la plus grande
collection d'objets de l'ancienne Égypte
chaque année plus de 2 millions de
personnes visitent ces salles afin
d'admirer les chefs qui ont survécu
pendant des milliers d'années et qui
raconte l'histoire mystérieuse d'une
civilisation qui ne cesse de nous
fasciner
[Musique]
un lieu magique où les signes évidents
de la grande civilisation des pharaons
se retrouve dans de longues séries de
salles de galeries et de grands cabinets
[Musique]
à chaque visite vous découvrez quelque
chose de nouveau soit quelque chose qui
se joue de la lumière lorsqu'elle
illumine les grandes cours au
rez-de-chaussée ou quelque chose qui
vous attire le long des murs sans fin
recouvert de sarcophages
[Musique]
jusqu'à ce qu'on découvre le merveilleux
masque du jeune Toutankhamon dont la
beauté à chaque fois coupe le souffle
comme si on le découvrait pour la
première fois
[Musique]
mais juste en dessous de toute cette
splendeur se trouve un mystérieux
labyrinthe la face cachée du musée
égyptien du Caire c'est caves un
labyrinthe de couloir et du tunnel qui
s'étend sous la place elle t'arrive une
caverne de trésor un pénétrable
débordant de chez d'oeuvre de l'Égypte
ancienne
[Musique]
YouTube le musée a été conçu pour
contenir environ 20 000 pièces mais
alors actuelle on en dénombre environ
200 000
un certain nombre sont exposés dans les
galeries supérieures où je me trouve
mais beaucoup se retrouvent dans les
couloirs étroits que constitue les
sous-sols du musée
pendant un siècle des objets provenant
de fouilles dans tout le pays ont été
amenés et stockés ici souvent sans même
être enregistrée ou archivé correctement
nettoyer et organiser le sous-sol c'est
presque comme participer à de nouvelles
fouilles et de très nombreux objets
intéressants sont mis à jour
pendant très très longtemps
le musée a tenu le rôle d'entrepôt
central pour toutes les Égypte
toute mission d’égypte qui trouvait un
objet la portée au Musée égyptien
pendant la première moitié du 10e siècle
l'Égypte décide de mettre un terme à une
pratique courante inadmissible
depuis des dizaines d'années les
étrangers en visitent avaient été
fascinés par la splendeur de la égyptien
et tentait de repartir avec une de ses
merveilleuses antiquités des obélisques
jusqu'au bijoux
[Musique]
il s'agissait essentiellement de
contrebandiers ou de négociants d'art
mais à même les grandes universités
européennes souhaitaient posséder une
belle pièce de cet héritage égyptien
jour après jour toutes sortes
d'antiquités disparaissaient des sites
archéologiques et se retrouver à
l'étranger et de trop nombreuses pages
de ce livre d'histoire risquaient de
rester blanche
[Musique]
en 1835 le Service des Antiquités
égyptiennes et fondée afin d'essayer
d'enrayer le pillage de ses trésors
on envisage de créer un lieu de
collection où on pourrait prendre soin
et examiner les chefs que le sol
égyptien offrait
quelques années plus tard les gyptologue
Auguste Mariette propose de construire
un musée
le projet gagnant est celui présenté par
l'architecte Marcel Dourdin
il marie une architecture moderne à des
éléments qui rappellent des temps plus
anciens
le plan du musée suit celui de la
disposition des temples égyptiens du Bas
Empire
tout comme dans les temples il n'y a pas
de partition claire entre les pièces
[Musique]
ce bâtiment de deux étages contient
environ une centaine de salles qui
entourent une course centrale
le musée est également équipé d'un
sous-sol destiné à être utilisé en tant
qu'entrepôt pour les objets en transit
à l'époque les antiquités parviennent
sans arrêt au musée et les archives sont
écrites à la main
rapidement les caisses sont stockées au
hasard et le sous-sol n'est plus qu'une
solution temporaire mais est devenue un
lieu d'entreposage permanent
nous emmène dans ses chambres secrètes
afin de nous faire découvrir quelques
trésors cachés
[Musique]
la personne qui fouille véritablement
les caves c'est Saba
le sous-sol de musée fait partie de Saba
et bien ici tous les jours elle ouvre
des boîtes des coffres etc
et elle a fait une découverte très
intéressante quelque chose trouvait en
1922 une tombe dans une cachette près
d'une porte nommée el Salah
cette tombe a été trouvée par un
archéologue français
les objets les plus étonnants de cette
tombe sont les scènes qui représentent
Anubis et wikovet elles sont vraiment
uniques
c'est très rare de trouver une stèle
avec des représentations d'Anubis et de
8.8 pour les Égyptiens des gyptes
ancienne
Anubis c'est le dieu des cimetières
le dieu des momies celui qui garde les
cimetières
et
celui qui ouvre la porte
Louxor Rivest
au fil du temps de nombreux temples et
complexes funéraires ont été construits
sur le site et ont laissé des trésors
extraordinaires
[Musique]
en 1891 on a trouvé dans le sable Bab el
ghasus c'est à dire la porte des prêtres
un site qui contenait une tombe avec 154
sarcophages
les momies avaient été parfaitement
conservées par les prêtres qui
pratiquaient les rites en l'honneur du
dieu Hamon
on en trouve quelques-unes dans les
sous-sols du musée
[Musique]
le secret du musée égyptien du Caire
sont étonnants
dans ce sous-sol il y a plus de 5 momies
dans un très bon état de conservation
comme les deux momies que voici
et on a trouvé plus de 150 sarcophages
sur la rive ouest de luxeur
en 1881 un membre de la famille
d'abdelazule une famille qui connaît les
secrets de la vallée de rois et la
rive-ouest de l'oxxor a trouvé une
cachette à plus de 10 mètres de
profondeur dans une fosse
c'est à l'intérieur que se trouvait les
momies des pharaons on a transporté plus
de 14 momies de Louxor au musée égyptien
du Caire 10 ans plus tard une nouvelle
découverte majeure se produit près du
lieu de la première découverte en 1891
une personne de la famille d'abdo
lassoul parle de l'emplacement de cette
cachette un archéologue français
quand ils pénètre il trouve les momies
du prêtre d'amande
parfaitement embaumé et dans des
sarcophages à inscription sublime
[Musique]
dans le couloir
si vous soulevez le couvercle vous
trouverez de belles momies
[Musique]
je pense que c'est momie et c'est
sarcophages pourrait être exposé dans
l'emporte quel musée
[Musique]
chaque antiquité apporte une nouvelle
pièce à la mosaïque complexe qui nous
raconte la vie des pharaons des dieux et
des gens ordinaires
les historiens sont restés longtemps
perplexes par les énigmes que posaient
les hiéroglyphes
tant que tous ces symboles restaient
silencieux la culture de l'Égypte
ancienne ne pouvait pas être
véritablement apprécié les énigmes
étaient à la fois importantes et
complexes
le 2 juillet 1798 les troupes du général
Bonaparte arrivent au Caire
le contingent militaire est accompagné
d'une commission scientifique composée
de 167 savants elle comprend des
astronomes des biologistes des géomètres
et des illustrateurs dont la mission est
de décrire l'Egypte et ses nombreuses
caractéristiques
une année après leur arrivée un soldat
découvre une pierre noire en basale qui
porte désinscriptions en hiéroglyphes et
en alphabet grec
il s'agit de la Pierre de Rosette la clé
qui va permettre de déchiffrer les
textes de l'ancienne Égypte
pendant 20 ans les inscriptions de la
pierre demeure silencieux et puis le 14
septembre 1822 le savant Jean-François
Champollion annonce qu'il est parvenu à
traduire la Pierre de Rosette
Champollion découvre que le hiéroglyphe
ne doivent pas être lu comme des
symboles qui décrivent des idées ou des
objets mais comme des signes phonétiques
laissons associer au symbole sont
cruciaux au déchiffrage
cette découverte élargit le champ des
possibilités et donne de nouvelles
perspectives à l'histoire de l'être
humain
[Musique]
la découverte de Champollion crée un
regain d'intérêt pour l'Égypte ancienne
que l'on dénomme encore aujourd'hui
égyptomanie et qui se répand dans le
monde entier
voici un objet que j'ai découvert il y a
25 ans
[Musique]
cette magnifique statue se trouvait à
l'intérieur de la tombe
j'ai commencé à nettoyer
et j'ai découvert ces statues
d'Aphrodite la déesse de la beauté et de
l'amour pour les Grecs
les Romains l'appellent Vénus déesse de
la beauté et de l'amour
les Égyptiens
l'appel hater la déesse de la beauté et
de l'amour
je tenais ma brosse à la main j'ai
commencé à la nettoyer j'ai découvert le
visage une partie du cœur et c'est là où
je me suis dit j'ai trouvé ma voix
l'archéologie
[Musique]
on peut apprendre beaucoup de choses
intéressantes de ce sous-sol il ne
s'agit pas que de découverte il s'agit
également des savants qui sont venus
afin d'analyser les objets et qui ont
commencé à nous raconter des histoires
que savons-nous de cet objet c'est un
blog de Pierre du granit c'est la partie
inférieure du statut quel statut nous
pouvons déduire de la cartouche ici
qu'il s'agit de nebma
et qui est né maître c'est un ménope 3
le père de toute ma vie le mari de la
Renty la femme la plus puissante de la
18e dynastie
le savant pensait que la statue
provenait d'Armand c'est une petite
ville au sud de luxe
[Musique]
Carnac et sans l'ombre d'un doute le
complexe architectural le plus
extraordinaire et imposant des gîtes
c'est la demeure du dieu Hamon que
chaque pharaon honore pendant des
siècles en construisant une partie de ce
temple le temple devient ainsi un
véritable labyrinthe de bâtiments sacrés
décorés de colonnes majestueuses
d'obélisques et de statues
[Musique]
le 3 octobre 1899 un tremblement de
terre détruit 11 colonnes et laisse la
cour principale en ruine
le site est reconstruit par un groupe
d'experts et en 1903 l'archéologue
Legrain découvre un par terre en
Allemagne
sous ce par terre se trouve une galerie
qui mène à une chambre où se trouve
17000 statues au bas mot
la plupart sont exposés dans le musée
mais une grande partie d'entre elles
restent cachée sous terre
[Musique]
cette magnifique statue
regardez la décoration le collier qui se
termine par haters
de la beauté et de l'amour
cette statue est en granit
et on voit aussi un morceau
la tête de Rams
c'est ce qui reste de cette découverte
majeure faite en 1903
le musée égyptien du Caire est
différence ou plusieurs aspects
le Musée égyptien ne collectionne pas et
n'achète pas
les objets nous parviennent sans qu'on
les demande
il existe d'autres musées qui sont comme
le Musée égyptien ils n'ont que des
antiquités égyptiennes
la collection n'est composée que d'art
de l'Égypte ancienne comme ceux de Turin
ou de Berlin
[Musique]
ce sont des dernières années des
archéologues de 20 pays nous ont apporté
ces objets des Français des Anglais des
Polonais des Américains des Hongrois des
Russes
ils ont découvert des statues des
poteries des momies et d'autres objets
super
[Musique]
a fait des fouilles sur le site de tel
el daba
[Musique]
le site de tel eldaba se trouve dans
l'est du delta du Nil sur la route de
l'ancienne capitale même fils vers le
Sinaï l'Institut archéologique
autrichien fouille le site depuis 1966
l'objet le plus intéressant qu'ils ont
trouvé
[Musique]
et la tête de quelqu'un qui n'est pas
égyptien de par le style de cette tête
il ne s'agit pas d'un égyptien mais d'un
Asiatique un dignitaire
il a une coiffure en forme de
champignons avec des cheveux roux et si
vous l'examinez attentivement vous
remarquerez qu'il a la peau jaune
la couleur de la peau des étrangers du
Nord dans la égyptien et cette très
curieux de trouver quelque chose comme
ceci en Égypte
mais qui est donc cet étranger
d'où venait-il et pourquoi venait-il à
Memphis
en Égypte on trouve un dignitaire
asiatique au service des pharaons qui
porte le titre de prince de la suite
royale
son travail consiste à organiser des
expéditions commerciales le commerce et
également peut-être des expéditions
minières au Proche-Orient
je pense que c'est l'explication la plus
probable à la présence de ces
dignitaires asiatiques
autre découverte extraordinaire faites à
Abusir une nécropole au nord de saqara
un site très important de sépultures
pour la cinquième dynastie
les experts ont trouvé une tombe intacte
à 25 mètres sous terre
elle fut construite par un homme
important nommé diophard le directeur
d'un bâtiment
c'est une des rares fois que l'on trouve
une tombe privée intact
[Musique]
le sarcophage pèse plus de 60 tonnes le
couvercle près de 30 ans
pourquoi ça parle ça nous a pris presque
une demi-journée pour déplacer le
couvercle vous imaginez comment ils ont
fait comment les anciens Égyptiens ont
déplacé le sarcophage
il creusait une fausse de 20 mètres
il remplissait la fosse du sable
posez le sarcophage sur le sable
creuser une autre fausse latérale qui
s'est remplissait du sable de la
première et lorsque le sable s'écoulait
le sarcophage descendait
[Musique]
dans cette boîte
on dénombre 408
sont des petites statues qui restent
derrière le défunt
et qui font le travail dans l'au-delà
que le défunt leur demande de faire
pourquoi 408
parce qu'il partent à la fin de la
journée c'est à dire chaque statut
travaille une journée donc
365 statues
puis il reste 35 statues qui sont des
contremaître
et 4 ou 8 directeur
fouillez dans le sous-sol du Musée
égyptien et passionnant
aucun autre lieu au monde nicite ni
musée ne peut nous en raconter en temps
sur l'Egypte ancienne que les sous-sols
du musée égyptien du Caire
[Musique]
le projet a commencé en 2004 le but est
de réorganiser ces antiquités et de les
montrer dans des conditions d'exposition
qu'elle mérite
[Musique]
je vais vous dire pourquoi quand je suis
devenu chef du département des
Antiquités j'ai décidé de changer le
sous-sol
quand j'étais jeune je suis allé sur un
site pour des fouilles
je ne voulais pas devenir archéologue je
détestais ce métier
tous les jours j'étais sous les tentes à
détester ces fouilles nous étions sur un
site archéologique important dénommé
comme Abou pilou
à l'époque je ne savais pas tout cela
nous avons découvert des temples des
cimetières des temples
[Musique]
chaque année je revenais avec plus de 60
boîtes dans un camion le directeur de
l'époque prenez les boîtes et les
déposer dans les caves
pendant des années je demandais au
directeur du musée égyptien du Caire où
se trouvait les boîtes en provenance de
combat boupilou
et nous les ont jamais trouvé qui n'en
savait rien jusqu'à ce que ça bat Vienne
dans ce sol et trouve les boîtes
au moins 50000 objets ont été
répertoriés mais en estime qu'il en
reste encore au moins 90 000
il y a trois ans quand nous nous sommes
rendus dans le sous-sol nous avons
décidé de travailler de créer un
registre et de tout mettre en ordre ce
fut un choc de découvrir que pendant
toutes ces années les boîtes n'avaient
même pas été étiquetés
nous ne savions même pas d'où elle
provenait nous avons fait nos propres
fouilles dans notre sous-sol
[Musique]
en Égypte le passé et le futur avancent
au même rythme
l'un et la richesse de l'autre
le nouveau musée enrichit le pays et
apporte un espace supplémentaire au
musée égyptien du Caire qui est devenu
trop petit au contenir tous les trésors
d'Égypte ancienne
le Conseil suprême des antiquités à un
programme de construction de nouveaux
musées
nous aurons environ 15 nouveaux musées
dans tout le pays
certains seront de petites structures
locales par exemple le lieu en lui-même
[Musique]
dans la construction d'un nouveau musée
a guisé qui surplombera les pyramides un
nouvel emplacement pour les trésors de
la tombe de Toutankhamon
les magnifiques antiquités qui ornent la
tombe de l'enfant roi seront transférées
et quitteront la galerie supérieure du
musée de la place el tarire pour
toujours
seul la momie de Toutankhamon qui repose
dans la Vallée des Rois restera derrière
l'autre grand musée de la civilisation
égyptienne se trouvera à Fustin
toujours au Caire
et il contiendra des objets d'Egypte
prédynastiques de la néolithique jusqu'à
nos jours
du Musée égyptien s'y trouveront
le musée sera un des seuls de ce genre
dans le monde arabe
il ouvrira ses portes en 2009 sur le
site de elfistax OK
ce sera le seul musée d'Egypte à
présenter toutes les époques de
l'histoire des chips
[Musique]
laissa la thèmes présenteront une
collection riche dé nombreux aspects
historiques de cet extraordinaire pays
l'Egypte compte sur le futur pour
présenter son plus grand trésor
son passé
[Musique]